[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talked about where we want and
today oh wait we can't do this huh no no
it's social distancing we're distancing
ourselves because of Coby but we will
cheers each other's drinks try this one
second half here we go here we go baby
here we go I gotta say I've never been
less excited to leave this place than I
am today today I'm going back home and
then I'm exhalation oh that's why you're
in isolation with your wife yeah but
you're know you're the best but but I'm
just talking about yeah I don't talk to
him very much different people here you
need to for energy is right yeah yeah
yeah I didn't realize how much I I enjoy
people too like I say it like I just
never really struck me as a lot of
people suck oh I got the opposite effect
know I've always been a very extroverted
person the older I'm getting the less
extroverted I'm getting and then by
being home alone all day every day for
the last week I'm like this is with the
kid too
well he's 12 he has his own life okay
yeah I got it like get all in our mix
and she be like what she's funny so I
was like we let her slide yeah what is
it like the younger kid like she almost
feels like a younger sibling versus our
kid how old 14 yeah is anybody here like
nervous about what's going on like
actually you'd like scared oh I'm scared
about is how people are reacting exactly
you spend enough time on Twitter I feel
like you you'll go crazy because of that
every time they like a warning goes out
like people go nuts and start buying up
all the supplies because they're crazy
y2k yeah and I feel like if we went on
lockdown or something and they start
running out of supplies people the crazy
ones are gonna start looting and acting
like we're in a [ __ ] apocalypse
what's crazy is you can't create the
apartment exactly
you can almost see a direct correlation
like if on the news there like we have
enough hand sanitizers everyone you go
to the store that's exactly the peanuts
out then they talk about toilet paper
it's just whatever the mean it's like
there's a direct correlation of people
freaking out with what's being put on
the medium because I think that we
manifest the physical reality from our
thoughts and our fears yeah yeah so if
everyone's scared about this thing
happening then it does happen like if
everyone's scared about all the toilet
paper running out now the toilet paper
is running out because they're all
scared about it like it wouldn't have
run out if people didn't get all scared
about it it would still be there the
crazier the craziest thing is like
everybody ran out and bought this hand
sanitizer I didn't buy it when
everybody's that [ __ ] home you're at
home you can wash it I understand buying
a couple bottles cuz you might menthol
make a store run or something like that
but most stores like have the wipes now
something like that so you ran out and
bought all of this stuff and God we got
willing where this passes shortly you're
just gonna be at home with like two
hundred bottles and nobody's gonna buy
it up you know what I think actually
happen is that is all the Goucher guys
they went out because it was a very
popular store yeah this guy goes out and
gets 35,000 bottles or whatever he goes
across four states he fills his entire
house was hand sani and then Amazon
shuts them down again good for that
price gouging is [ __ ] that an ethical
it's a more all that [ __ ] right but I
think that's what happened with hands
Hanny I think toilet paper is a whole
different story
yeah twelve paper I don't know why the
[ __ ] everyone's buying clothes ever but
ain't nobody selling toilet paper you
know what I think it is remember why
it's UK yeah so last wave panic yeah
because they're like you're 2000 the
computers aren't ready they can't handle
it going back to zero they'll gonna
they're gonna freak out everyone started
to buy enough toilet paper and water
bottled stuff and I think because we
haven't had another like global panic
before that's the only one they were
members were like 20-year reunion of the
[Music]
because this thing about y2k is like
their computers they're smarter than us
goats like zero zero zero one like you
don't remember they were saying like
yeah that all the electrical grids are
gonna go out we're gonna be left with no
power yeah I remember
all of that but I'll say even then I was
like you know like terminators would be
so disappointed in us they wouldn't even
have to like armed themselves to the
team they would just come on just like
you guys are stupid robots that were
working okay back then was like Robby
the Robot flipping pennies in his mouth
I remember 19 1999
December 31st and we were watching the
TV because Australia was the first one
to hit y2k and so everyone was like dude
Australia get [ __ ] and they did it
they're like we're fine and then
everyone's like there was a ride
kangaroos ass and China's you know and
then China's like we still have two
months no but you know what though I
actually had a mini panic attack because
of all this yes so you remember that day
where Jess sent us that audio message
about oh yes a bull lockdown and blah
blah like all that stuff immediately cuz
I had just had I had just woken up when
I that was the first thing that I did
when I woke up was listen to that audio
message and I woke up and I started
shaking and I started crying because we
had no food in the house zero food like
we were like oh yeah because you guys
had just moved in just moved in we were
waiting so the next day we were gonna
get a brand new refrigerator so that's
why we were putting off going grocery
shopping for the longest time it was
last Friday right I think it was yeah
last Friday and then Casey wasn't home
and like Isaac was going and accused at
school and so I don't know like all this
like immediately I just felt like this
insane amount of like panic cuz I'm like
we're gonna be locked in here with no
food we're gonna die we're gonna die
we're not gonna make it
and then that's when like I started
texting you guys and I'm like oh my god
I had to do a 10 minute meditation to
calm down cuz that was the real [ __ ]
like how we're actually feeling about
this but this thought you also have so
many friends we live like five minutes
away where
I think like it kind of really black
tunnel vision it's not logical yeah the
human body can survive without food for
seven days so we'll begin for say how
long can you survive without a haircut
Casey imagines not eating for six whole
days even never was seven true I think
that I think about when I had to put
myself in that type of situations like
to him I'm gonna look so good
when I lose this weight like this that's
that would be the only reason that we're
going like naked and afraid come back
often afraid they're like 17 or 25
survivor I'm like yeah I'll do it it
always bums me out when I see the
survivor like the fight finale because
they've always had a couple months and
they always look kind of fatter and I'm
like well yeah once we went grocery
shopping and there was like I saw food
in the pantry food in the fridge you're
like how was go shoe shopping it wasn't
that crazy like it was pretty I've never
seen a grocery store like that okay I
have I have like the day before
Thanksgiving is like the only other time
you really see the grocery store is
acting a little crazy like that but I
had never seen multiple shelves empty
did you tell you we ran into each other
oh yeah yeah he told me yeah you know
he's giving me tips on how to had a
maneuver on the the grocery store and
they were like no carts and I'm like I
went to a store the same day you went to
the store because I was like oh [ __ ] was
the day that they announced the state of
emergency and that's what was like kind
of scary because it was like Oh what do
we have right now like could we survive
off this and another thing we didn't
really have was like fresh produce or
leaving frozen vegetables and stuff so I
went to the store Steve went to a store
in Studio City with all the like boogy
boogy ass [ __ ] then I went to
the one in Van Nuys it's two different
types of neighborhoods and he's like
everything's cleaned out all the produce
everybody
tofu's gone they can't go
there's no sprouts yeah does that slowly
no Seurat forget it all the toilet paper
and hand sanitizers are gone but all the
fruits and vegetables completely still
all the nation what neighborhood you're
in yeah yeah it's a Mexican neighborhood
that way potatoes gone rice gone pasta
gone sweet potatoes buy the [ __ ]
bucket there was gluten-free pasta was
all that one food stock to the brim I
was like Oh give us some of these pita
burritos I know what's the craziest
things like every movie that you've seen
thus far that talks about like a
pandemic or aliens attack it's not like
that it's the exact same thing that
happened with their government happen
with yeah like it's no big deal doll
it's not even a big deal people getting
cured thousands by the date hundreds of
thousands by today by tomorrow I want
him to be a theme and then it went to
like okay it might be a little more
serious than we thought but it's no need
to panic
everybody just relax nothing's gonna
happen nobody's getting locked down then
the next week all right god this is
Delta Red Code Red
we're implementing a media shelter in
process guys don't go anywhere just like
and then the press there was like I take
no responsibility for what happened this
is not my fault
dudes like bro you told everybody relax
it's like it just chilled they literally
said this is not a big deal but he's
like let's say my fault man I'm from
China
it's like what they have done absolutely
exactly what the movies have taught us
and then we find out like like movies
aren't real and this is the house no but
it was exactly how this is why the
government look this is a very small
thing right compared to this is a good
tester it's a great tester just this
isn't like 50% of people can die or yeah
this is a great tester but this is why
the government can tell us about the
aliens think this [ __ ] everyone's
freaking the [ __ ] out my [ __ ] if we knew
about aliens civilization would be
ending right now hello
man and we'd be sitting to JK there
you'd be burning it around what if it
was like eased in like how it has been
used in in Hollywood like we but they
try to ease this and we still freaking
the [ __ ] out here well I don't think
that ease it in it I think they they
just lied about they blatantly lied
about they knew the stats right and they
knew that if you come into contact with
someone that you can be a Triscuit I
just didn't think I think they thought
they they would have a better handle on
it but it's like when have you ever had
a good handle or independent that's why
I don't trust the government at all
exactly then they wanted to surround it
because I got I'm big on all the
conspiracies that are going on so what's
the conspiracy that you feel like it is
it was generated in lab and movin
generator in the lab by the Chinese
government but there's also create
American plant to could because it cuz
art only a lot to believe in one like
all of them and the American plant idea
is that China is an enemy of us right
the terrors and all that stuff
Iran hasn't always been that nice to the
US but where where is it that it's been
hit the hardest Iran China
what about Italy Italy well there's a
lot of smokers why Iran Casey why Iran
let me tell you why this is so much
about the way that the world really
works that Iran has denied Iran's top
leaders constantly there's so close to
China they constantly moonlight in China
they [ __ ] around China probably [ __ ]
Chinese prostitutes all kinds of stuff
they're very connected to the Chinese
government especially the higher levels
of Chinese government so who hits sick
first in Iran the [ __ ] top leaders of
Iran like they're all bunch of those
guys have died out since then so that's
the point right is that you start to see
exactly where everyone's allegiances are
when you see who's dying where and who
has thank you it's like getting an STD
and then one person gets it and then the
next person I get so you're like oh so
you do want that person yeah man it is
like that it's so fascinating but this
is why I never took the [ __ ]
government man they could hide the
sniffles the Iranian people try to
couldn't hide the sniffles and they they
killed scientists try to hide it
like the world has tried to keep this
whole thing like like tamp down because
obviously you don't want to incite a
panic but at the same time I'm not
scared in America because we have very
low rate I'm not scared of the death
rate but the economic impact people
losing their job amen
it's like the cops are behind me that
feeling get with the castle behind you
that's what I'm feeling
safety all time like I'm about to get a
hug from behind
wow you feel a hug with somebody that
doesn't have pants on it's fully erect
and I'm pink I got my mother's hips
saying so in the u.s. I'm more scared of
yet economic yeah like people are few I
feel so bad for you losing their jobs
right now I'm just like man that's
that's gonna hurt a lot more about
getting out of this is if that's gonna
hurt a lot more than what I think the
repercussions of people actually getting
sick and dying is so that's Sunday the
mayor came out Garcetti he came out and
shut down movie theaters gyms fitness
studios and as you know I own a gym and
so we have to shut down and then so for
two weeks two weeks our members can't
come in and but the part that I hurt the
most is all of my staff their hourly
workers right so they need to put in the
hour to get paid and a lot of these kids
because they're working hourly wages
they don't plan ahead like months ahead
so they don't really have savings where
they're counting on these hours yeah so
those guys I feel the worst about so me
and Gio we forego our by two or three
months of our gym paid so we just pay
them upfront and we'll figure out what
we're gonna do later because a lot of
these guys are like [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
do I do is really nice I know a lot of
small businesses right now who are
forced to like lay off their employees
so that they have the best chance to get
unemployment so that like they can
collect unemployment so they're
basically like will roll temporarily lay
you off and will rehire you as soon as
we can if they can't even
come back from it yeah that's a lot of
unrest we need to come back through yes
we weren't filming at a camp studio a
couple days ago and there's this candy
store on the corner of West is studio
now on this intersection there literally
like eight schools like middle schools
high schools elementary is right and
they got that location specifically
because of the schools in the area well
all the schools are closed yeah you know
is that like you plan for them like
November to like January for it to be
slow why it's Christmas break here's a
holiday you plan all year for that but
with something like this happens and
then like this is a big in another year
like this not even spread wouldn't be
spring break when they said everything
down so it's like how do you come back
from that yeah yeah and like how many
airlines are gonna stay in business I
remember like uh like Oh 20 years ago or
whatever bunch of airlines went out of
business because they couldn't keep up
with after 9/11 happened they couldn't
like all the ticket prices were way too
low and like they couldn't keep up so a
lot of airlines would I business feel
like the same things gonna happen I'm
gonna be honest with you outside Adel to
this office I really don't care other
places I just don't like the way they
treat us like with the charges well it's
more so like like the fees like yeah
fees are credit axes that they already
hit to it and then the change we that's
$150 change me every time shame on you
American okay shame on [ __ ] Vegas for
all the resort fees - oh my god right
we're closing hotels right now and I'm
like [ __ ] good [ __ ] they charge was
all fees and they don't have [ __ ]
breakfast like how do you gonna charge
me a resort yeah how do you know what
that is well it's just a waiter for
dinner though extra taxes don't even
legal why is an extra forty bucks a day
it's like yeah it's like double whatever
your your trip is you can double it and
then you have to also put down like the
deposit so like you have to pay for the
room taxes resort fee and then $50 a day
deposit shame on you to Vegas but you
know what Vegas also knows that that
will so keep coming so [ __ ] you man
I just come to the week that is a
Tuesday through Thursday you can clean
up in Vegas that's thirty three dollars
a night go to [ __ ] banyan oh yeah you
spend $15 Matt's plate for 17 hours free
man finish lots of free drinks all you
do is just about the slap any casinos
even open right now I think most of my
clothes will be there
yeah you could you know Circus Circus
Circus Circus is like did the building
burn down then we're still open for
business that exact what happened oh
yeah yeah true well I'll cigarette
smoking suckers suckers probably kills
Kobe I know I'm not a fan though like I
think I think a lot of these big
companies like I heard that the some of
the airline's already approached the
government like hey we need to fit the
billion dollar bailout it was like bro
we need a rent bailout I'm hearing that
yo we're not gonna hit you with the
eviction notice or anything like that
that's that's cool but yeah reasonable
will be we're going to pause rent yeah
telling me you're not gonna hit me with
a fictional this means that all right
well we'll take this much away and we'll
put it at the end it's still building up
so that what about the poor rent or was
like all I need my mama $6,000 but like
if you are paying if they're paying like
a mortgage on that and they're renting
it out to tenants like they stopped to
pay the mortgage but here's the thing
though like let's say the mortgage on
this building is ten thousand dollars
right but from every renter you're
getting thirty five four thousand
dollars right so you've made mortgage
yeah that's that's what I'm saying I'm
like even he's mom please I said a small
complex it's like eight eight units of
mine but I know like from what I'm
paying and like I don't even have the
biggest apartment but I know from what I
paying me and one other person pays the
mortgage on a building and there's six
other units I hope they suspend taxes
suspend taxes well they they push back
to get it push my taxes for ninety days
perfect they just take taxes away for
this year's I beep ah man
they should honestly for stimulus like
they should do the one year my whole
thing is the government imposed this
problem on us like like the reason why
you can't go out and go to the bar or
whatever obviously it's because of
copa90 but the government's the ones
saying stay home but but the government
monetize the government's the ones
saying stay home right so so it's on
them to to make up the difference order
and be honest would you like this this
thousand dollars a month stimulus is it
is helpful in Montana like like
literally bro that's the number here
what depends because if you have a
family of three say or four I think you
get like three grand maybe so are they
gonna do it family base that's why I
heard yeah that would be great but like
just doing it like a thousand dollars
like bro like what that's not even rent
that what you're losing and let's not
even utilities and food and the only
thing you're saving on right now is gas
they're not like like car insurance
isn't giving us a break up the shows
isn't giving us a break till it doesn't
give them a break Netflix sure doesn't
give me a break okay my question is you
know how they always talk about like the
Nash nation Nash national debt debt
mm-hmm
what is that about because doesn't the
government have money or like why is it
in that out of the whole commerce not in
trillions like that yeah we don't I mean
that's we don't have the liquid how
thing to pay the debts like we're a debt
to what countries are we in China well
mainly China mainly China so we we have
debt to them it's I'm thinking like if
the government would decide it which
they will probably wouldn't but just
like okay pause on every transaction or
like whatever everyone's in a crisis
right now on no more mortgages no more
fees number whatever just freeze all
movement would they be able to cover it
no if we book but the guy we're gonna
buy a bunch of China gift cards so
basically right if they freeze all of
that then all of these all of the places
that are freeze are gonna actually
bellhops so the entire like real estate
like I'm sure would acts for government
for 100 billion dollar bailout is like
oh well windows the money because the
tenants on man
so we are the still there
all this up like somebody in a bit or
the banks are gonna hack for more money
for bailout but he's like oh well these
people can't pay their mortgage on these
properties so we have to take this off
somebody's gonna take that loss I just
don't think it should be the little man
because these businesses have checks and
balances set up in place and their
insurance for them to be covered for
stuff like this the same thing what I
feel like this that happens when you
have somebody Simpson fall and work
workmen's comp like those type of
assurances are set up in places for
emergencies like this only people that
don't have emergencies Wall Street I was
hoping that you know I just hope that
we'd be on Wall Street again I really do
I will backhand you out of that
[Music]
[Music]